there's an exclusive weapon so let's
check out this let's this is the Jade
wrap this is the Jade rabbit now before
we get too deep into the weeds on all
this gear left did Robin show the show
the viewers at home whoa new optics on
board your Jade rabbit so every time I
highlight a bad guy Young's I'll read
indeed so when I highlight you deej I'm
no time I am I am friendly let me not
good when you over I'm doing my friend
Lee dance for dinner party yep that's
not how you play nice with others
alright it's just because they love you
i know bow i am hanging back bobgoblin
is still trying to help get it that's a
negative rusty breaker okay I got my
super right again I'm ready to go all
yeah go get him go get that Minotaur
over there he's pissing me I want to get
here I loosen the jar for you I'm gonna
save it yep he's head by the way i can
confirm Cyclops bad guy yeah yeah I
dread very good not come overi every
good sniper needs a spotter that's what
you're doing for us oh whoa dodged Oh
Cyclops is down he's got a bunch of
little goblins near him though copy have
Cyclops
you